[Music]
do you know if there's any 17 year old
landlords out there yeah i 17 year old
landlord that's a thing so that's a
thing so that's the thing
we just keep saying today i bought my
first rental property at 17. the
property that i purchased is beachfront
and currently has one house on it which
we will turn into five the property is
currently
765 square feet and ultimately has
potential to be four thousand squares we
will build in front on top and in the
back find the best renters to rent it
out to for the rest of my life i'm so
excited to start the construction
process here's the inspiration for it
and on top follows the updates
let me tell you right now if if if a 17
if i found out my landlord was a 75 year
old pissed no i wouldn't be pissed oh
you want me to pay rent come [ __ ] get
it
yeah okay
oh you you want my rent money cool
come get it
i'm gonna just put it on the table and
i'm gonna i'm gonna let my cousin hang
out here lady as well if you can get
through her you could have the rent
money a 17 year old man yeah i mean
something tells me you know someone else
you know behind the scenes i mean it
says with the expertise of my dad yeah
the part where a 17 year old can't get a
mortgage
or a business loan yeah
so you didn't buy your first rental
property you gave your parents some
money and then they were like oh what a
we'll get you your first rental property
yeah and then it's in their name and
then when you get out of college you're
like i need my rental property now
they're like no yeah
by the way like you know there's nothing
wrong with
uh someone that's this age learning the
economics of something like this at all
but don't like flex don't flex it like i
just did this i just did this i just did
this you didn't you know most of the
comments are like this is this is so
good like wow you're creating wealth for
yourself which she is but then one of
them one of the comments was like um i'm
a business major and this is the
smartest thing you can do with your
money
cool i'm a business major good for
i'm not even in business school just uh
i did my freshman and sophomore years of
my business major and trust me
i know
this is the smartest thing you can do
with your money out of all the things
you can do with your money you'll get
there yeah you'll like you'll you'll
come to know what i know already because
i'm two years into my business yeah
you're just 17. you made a good move but
like was the help of your dad and like
you're just 17. maybe uh you know once
you're in college for a couple years as
a business major you know you'll learn
the things that i've learned i think
which is really this is the right move
yeah then you'll really appreciate what
you've done for yourself but like as of
right now you're not quite a business
major so you can't quite understand what
you're doing for yourself yeah that's
why you need your dad's help yeah
so
shout out to your dad he's probably
business major
that's just funny yeah i was saying the
smartest thing you can do with your
money
i was saying that we need to create a
hotline for landlords getting bullied
are you a landlord who owns property in
a time of difficulty and your tenants
are saying mean things about you because
you won't help them out during a
pandemic
call us we'll make you feel better
something like that that's good i don't
know why i did that to you
why
it's made eye contact for the whole
monologue lord yeah
it doesn't appeal to you i'm not a
landlord yeah please don't hate me
i'm not one cody just checked out on
that script i gave to him he's like i'm
not a landlord so
i don't get like people hate landlords
but what i don't what is the alternative
to landlords um
how else would it work i guess taxes and
the government buys you housing it would
be like social housing yeah for for
everyone yeah so the government would
buy up properties and then let the
communities run those properties
but isn't that like socialism yeah yeah
that is the alternative austria does it
about 60 of their population lives in
social housing
interesting
so that would be the alternative yeah
get it yeah cool got it i'll tell you
what uh a 17 year old owning my building
that's [ __ ] up
that's what i'm saying i'd be mad just
because like they're doing way better
than me i would pee on the walls i would
i would [ __ ] on the carpet i would what
are you telling me the person who owns
this four-story beachside building is 17
years old
i'd punch holes through the drywall
because i'm mad and yeah because you
just want to do damage yeah and then i'd
knock on my neighbor's door and i'd be
like hey let's keep punching
until we get to the other side as a
business major i'm gonna give you your
first lesson in owning a property
sometimes you need the security deposit
that's the smartest thing you can do
with everything here here's why
i think people hate landlords
it's because they're 17. landlords stink
man landlords are the [ __ ] worst i
mean landlords typically don't have a
good rap because like
they just always end
yeah they just end up owning a lot of
property and then they just you know
then they hand it off to the management
company and they don't give a [ __ ] you
know
oh your your ninth property the water
heater is broken and they found asbestos
in the pipe yeah and the kit it's like
poisoning your tenant's newborn baby
they're like
telling them to move yeah that is true
actually i like my old landlord but when
my place filled with [ __ ] water
he was pretty like apologetic but like
he basically wanted to get us back in
the place as fast as he could so we
could continue paying rent yeah because
we didn't pay for when we were the time
the time we were out yeah he like
didn't repair the floors you know
there's black water just sitting on the
floors for like days and days it soaks
in it causes mold and all that [ __ ]
bacteria whatever
so you're supposed to redo the whole
floors like new wood newer like go down
to the bottom and redo the whole thing
the whole thing and he just sanded it
down and resealed it so that we could
just get back in there
and it's like i can't imagine how much
just fecal bacteria is sealed underneath
that
sealant now he's going to let someone
move in there not knowing that that
thing was a was you know a mcdonald's
ball pit full of [ __ ] one landlord
listening to this be like hey i'm a nice
[ __ ] guy yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying
there's gotta be some landlords out
there that are nice yeah def there are
like three
yeah there's three it's three nice
landlords dude yeah no do every every
time i see one of those guys on tick
tock that's like i own 400 properties
like you ever seen that one where
they're all like drinking at that bar
and it goes around the circle and he's
like
i own 400 properties
net worth of 50 million dollars then it
moves to the next guy he's like i own
570 properties and it keeps getting
bigger and bigger and one of the guys
owns like 50 000 apartment buildings or
something
like jesus christ yeah the landlord
final boss yeah
it's so crazy to think that
a one person can
collect all the rent on so many people
if all the people knew that one person
was collecting the rent and they all
were just like we're not going to do it
yeah what can he do yeah what could he
actually do if he comes here let's just
you know what are you going to take us
50 000 people now they're all occupied
in the building and they have his
picture on everything that this full
comes near the building
don't give him any money and beat his
[ __ ] ass
so i mean that's what it needs to be is
if if
on the like on the west side if the rent
is too high all the all the tenants need
to rise up where they just say [ __ ] that
we're not paying any rent
and they just like decide how much money
amongst themselves are gonna pay someone
to like you know take care of the trash
take care of this take care of that and
so the landlord's like hey you guys
can't it's like can't what
but then he can't pay the mortgage and
then he gets foreclosed and then they
gotta move out anyways squat it to squat
okay [ __ ] yeah i'm just you know i'm
just trying to inspire uprising against
the landlords and just select areas of
the nation
i'm just kidding patreon i'm not trying
to you know inspire riots
but if you're landlord 17 don't pam
you